(upbeat music)
- Welcome to Ear Biscuits,
the podcast where two lifelong friends
talk about life for a long time.
I'm Rhett.
- And I'm Link,
this week, at the round
table of dim lighting,
we are exploring your nostalgic memories,
because we put out a prompt,
@mythical on Twitter,
so be looking out there if
you wanna interact with us
and for us to read some
of your submissions
and talk about it.
The prompt that we put
out into the world is,
"What's one thing you could
bring back from childhood
that you wish you could,
if you would, would you, do you?"
You can't, but you want to.
- People took it
in different ways, and it got
us thinking about some things.
So we're gonna talk about your
childhoods, our childhoods.
- We're talking about some
entertainment practices,
we're talking about some toys,
we're talking about
some school experiences.
We rounded up some good stuff
which ring that old nostalgia bell.
- Ding, ding.
- We like to look backwards fondly,
'cause, hey, we lived
it all together, man.
Starting in first grade.
- Well, I mean,
I spent some time alone,
I had some girlfriends
that I got wrapped up with for a while.
- Yep, and you kinda left me in the dust.
- Well, you could've done the same,
you had the freedom to do the same thing.
- Well, yeah, but I had.
- And maybe even more
opportunity to do that
and still didn't take advantage of it.
- I had a Nintendo,
I had a television.
- Well, so did I,
I had a Sega.
- I know you did, yeah.
- A, B and C buttons.
- I think we were over the Nintendo
by the time you started
getting into the girls,
hot and heavy.
(Rhett and Link laughing)
But we'll get into all of that stuff,
but first, I just wanted
to share an experience,
it's something that happened to me,
something that I participated in.
- Usually that's what
an experience is. (laughing)
- Something I can
take credit for. (laughing)
- This is an experience
that happened to me.
- But when I shared it with my family,
none of them believed me.
- They didn't appreciate it.
- Well, no, they didn't even
believe that it happened.
- Okay, well, all right.
- They thought I was making it up.
I told Lily and then I'm
pretty sure she believed me,
'cause I thought I had proof,
and then separately I
told Christy and Lincoln
and they didn't believe me.
And then when I got Lily to
tell them what I told her,
turns out, I thought she believed
me, but she didn't either.
So now I'm gonna tell
you the experience and.
- Oh, I'm not gonna believe you.
- Maybe you won't believe me either.
Maybe I am lying, maybe this
is just a sensational story
that I just made up for entertainment,
and for some reason,
you along with my family
and everybody listening will just say,
"There he is again."
- You're gonna do
a lot of damage to the reputation
of yourself and this podcast
if you're going to lie about
something that happened to you,
because we do not do that.
- Some stories are so good.
- Sometimes we're mistaken
about some things that happened to us,
but we never intentionally
lie about anything.
- Until right now,
potentially.
(Rhett laughing)
- Okay, all right.
- You be the judge.
So you know how my backyard works,
it's pavers in a patio,
the whole backyard's a
pool and then a patio,
there's no lawn back there,
and then on.
- Neither of us
have any grass.
- You have some fake grass.
- I have some fake grass,
you have grass in the front.
- Yeah, I have a lawn in the front,
but in the back, I just have,
the pavers go all the way to this wall
that is like a pony wall,
it's like 2 1/2 feet off the ground,
and then there's like this
cabling thing above that.
- You ever try to keep a pony up there
just to see if it would cross it?
- I think the pony would stay in
because it's kinda like a fence,
and then when you walk close to the edge,
which this is, I was gonna
be doing some grilling.
- You saw something, didn't you?
- And I look down into my
neighbor's yard below me.
- Aw, you saw your
neighbors doing something.
- I'm on the hill, when I look
down, I'm pretty elevated,
so I can look down and see,
like if they're outside eating, let's say,
and they've got a table of food,
I'm at such a height and vantage point
that I could see the
whole top of the table
and everything that they're eating.
If anybody has a bald
spot, I can see that,
I'm looking down on these people,
literally, not figuratively.
- Right.
- I don't even know them
that well.
- But your house is higher,
so it makes it, I mean,
you are kinda also looking
down on them figuratively,
'cause the higher the house on
the hill, the better, right?
You wanna be on the top row.
- Well, I don't wanna say that,
but I'd like for you to say it about me.
- Okay, the higher the house
on the hill, the better.
You wanna be the guy with
the house at the top of hill.
Actually.
- I'm not all the way
at the top.
- Then you're a target,
you wanna be the guy right next to the guy
who's at the top of the hill.
- I don't really look,
I go out my front door
and then there's a street
and there's people on the other side,
so like no one in their
backyard is looking down at me.
Like your neighbor in his backyard
can look over and look down on you.
- But he really has to get
a very intentional.
- He's gotta work at it.
- And it has happened a couple of times
where I'll be in my,
I like to be scantily clad in my backyard
'cause it feels very private,
and (sighing) everyone once in a while,
I can't remember his name,
he's introduced himself several times,
but he'll just be
standing up there, "Hey,"
and I'm just like, "Hey."
- And your naked?
- I haven't been naked yet,
I mean, I haven't been naked where,
I think if he saw me naked.
- He wouldn't say, "Hey."
- He would turn around
and walk back.
- I don't know the couple
that lives down below me,
it's a totally different street
that accesses their house,
it's like, we're like
backyard neighbors, right,
so it's kind of a strange,
and they're so far down there.
- You wouldn't even know
how to drive to their house.
- I haven't really had
an interaction with them,
I wanted to because
they had this huge tree
in their side yard that basically,
it blocks some of my view,
but it was huge.
- Don't get me started
with neighbors' trees, man.
- I know.
- You know that is
a sore subject for me.
- Well, they chopped it down,
which gave me a better view,
but it just seems pretty open.
But I'm not gonna hold that against 'em.
And I guess I'm looking
for opportunities to like.
- You had a problem with the tree
and they cut it down.
- Put my best
foot forward.
- And you're not gonna hold it
against 'em, I don't understand the logic.
- I had a problem with
them cutting down the tree
because I liked it.
- Oh, you liked it,
okay, you liked the tree.
- Yeah, 'cause I'm at
such a height that like I was eye level
with the middle and top of the tree.
- The foliage.
- I felt like
I was in their tree.
- Yeah.
- I could see like birds
at eye level.
- Yeah.
- It was awesome.
- Right.
- Big old tree.
But I wanna mend fences, I'm
looking for opportunities.
I literally look over,
'cause I'm out there,
I'm gonna start grilling,
and then I smell, there's like this like,
"Ooh, it smells good, somebody's
grilling out down there,"
and I look over.
- I have no idea what you're about to say.
- And it's one of those grills,
it's just like a rectangular grill
with like shish kebab
just going across it,
like what I call lulay,
you got chicken shish kebab
and then you got the lulay shish kebabs,
and boy, that stuff smells so good.
- Just a long piece of meat.
- Yeah, and they're grilling it out,
and I look over and I see the
guy who lives in the house,
he's an older guy, he might be 60,
before I knew it, I found
myself yelling at him,
"Smells good." (laughing)
- Oh, okay,
hold on, hold on.
- I'm such a redneck.
- Hold on, hold on, hold on,
had he made eye contact with you
before you said, "Smells good?"
- No.
- Big mistake, just right off the bat,
big mistake.
- I said, "Smells good."
And he looked up at me,
and then I said, I didn't think
about any of this ahead of time.
- Well, I mean, yeah,
you're Link. (laughing)
- I'm going totally on instinct,
and I'm like, "Throw me
a piece of that meat."
- Oh, God, (laughing) no.
What is wrong with you, man?
- I said, "I'll catch it,"
and I held my hand out like that.
And then I looked from
him to like this woman
that was standing next to him
to see what her reaction was,
and they were all just kinda
like, I guess, taken aback
that this guy was yelling.
- "Throw me a piece of
that meat, I'll catch it."
- "Smells good."
And then out of the corner of my eye,
as I was surveying how the crowd
was responding to my friendliness,
I see a piece of meat flying in the air.
- (laughing) Hold on, hold on, hold on,
okay, hold on.
(Link laughing)
So you specifically called
for meat to be thrown at you
and then you're surprised when it happens,
what is wrong with you, man?
- No, I wasn't, well, yeah,
I was a little surprised,
it was one of those
friendly neighbor things
that I just thought I was saying,
just like, "Smells good, throw
me a piece, I'll catch it."
- What, and there's, you didn't catch it.
- So again, it was just
out of my periphery,
and just like a cat, I just instinctively,
it wasn't coming at me, it
was going far to my left,
I lunged over, and you know how,
above the pony wall, cement wall,
there's like those cables
that prevent someone from like
standing on the pony wall,
if they were a toddler or something,
and then just like careening over.
- Yeah.
- Tumbling all the way down
into the neighbor's yard.
So I reached as far as I could,
I bent over that cable.
- 'Cause he was throwing it short.
- He threw it short
and to his right, to my left.
- They always throw it short,
yeah.
- And I reached over like this
and bent down, and if he had thrown it
even more to the right, just a millimeter,
I would not have caught it.
- You caught the meat?
- I snagged it,
and I did catch it.
And I held it up and I said, "I got it."
And I took a bite out of it,
it was a strip of lulay about that long.
- Was it cooked?
- It was cooked, I took a bite out of it
and I was like, "Man, that's good."
And the woman turned to
the man who threw it,
and said, "Wow, that was
a really good throw."
And I said, "No, that
was a really good catch."
(Rhett and Link laughing)
- Okay.
- And I took another bite.
- So did somebody who had
already been served meat
who had it on their plate throw it
or did the guy who was grilling throw it?
- The guy who was grilling threw it.
- And it was a surprise?
- No, I yelled and then I
was looking at other people,
so I didn't see him actually throw it.
And I said to him, "You know what,
I didn't see you throw it, I
just saw the meat in midair
and I just happened to reach over
and I was able to catch it."
- Did they clap?
- They didn't clap,
and then after.
- What did he say?
- He didn't say anything.
And I ate the meat, and I was like,
"Yeah, it was a good catch,"
and they kinda laughed a
little bit, but not really,
and then they just went back
to what they were doing,
there was no conversation.
I was smiling and I was like,
I might've said one more
thing, I don't know,
but it didn't lead to
like a budding friendship
like I thought it would.
And I had a little piece of
the meat and I went inside,
and I just felt like I
needed to tell somebody,
and Lily was playing video
games and I told Lily the story,
and like I said, I didn't
think she wouldn't believe me,
especially 'cause I showed her
the piece of meat that I still had.
- Where's a man gonna get a piece of meat
just walking outside?
- So later, when I told Lily and Lincoln,
I mean, Christy and Lincoln.
- Whatever their names are.
- They didn't believe me,
I said, "Ask Lily, she
saw the piece of meat."
And then Lily came out later,
and I was like, "Tell 'em what I did,"
and she was like, "Well, Dad said
that he caught a piece of meat,
but like, (laughing) I don't believe him."
(Rhett laughing)
And I'm like,
"Lily, I had the meat in my hand,"
and she was like, "Well, I
saw something in your hand,
but like you could've had
anything in your hand."
And I was like, "What, no one believes,"
so do you believe me?
- No, not for a second.
- And then I was like, "Fine,
no one's gonna believe me,"
we're sitting out by the fire pit
eating the dinner that I grilled
and their party down.
- Was it as good?
- Not as good, their party
had disbanded by this point,
no one was outside.
- You don't even know this guy's name.
- I don't know his name,
he doesn't know my name.
- He threw you meat.
- He threw me meat.
He walked out.
- I mean,
that's first-name basis stuff
right there.
- I know, man,
he walked out, and I was like,
"There he is right there,
you guys don't believe me,"
so I leaned over and I looked,
and I was like, "Hey,
I just told my family
"about catching your meat."
(Rhett laughing)
"And you know what,
they don't believe me."
And he looked up at me,
and he kinda smiled and nodded his head,
but there wasn't an audible laugh.
And then he grabbed
something off of his girl
and he went back in.
- Walked back inside?
- He didn't say anything.
I was like, "My family didn't believe me,"
and he didn't say anything.
- You gotta go front door,
this is a knock on the front door,
and say, "Hey, we gotta talk."
- You gotta back me up, man,
you're gonna throw me
meat and then deny it,
keep silent on it?
- I don't think it's about him
validating your story at this point,
I just think it's about,
you have to acknowledge
this level of connection that you've made.
- It was cool, man, like,
I mean, like I have an abrasion on my arm
where I, look at that.
- [Rhett] Well, that
doesn't prove anything.
- That's from the cable.
- In fact,
now that you're showing me that,
it's making me doubt your whole story.
- 'Cause I reached over, it was heroic.
- You don't have to show me scars.
- It was a heroic catching of meat.
(Rhett sighing)
And I mean, he threw the meat
as far as a man could
throw a piece of lulay.
- Well.
- It could not have been
thrown farther.
- You do understand what the next stage
in this relationship is?
- You back to that assert dominance stuff?
- No, no, this isn't
like your other neighbor
where you had to assert dominance.
- They put up a fence, by the way.
- Oh, really?
- Yeah, they can't see me
in my shower anymore, through the window
on my shower.
- You think they watched
the vlog?
- I think they did.
- Yeah, this is an assert
dominance situation,
this is a kinship, this is camaraderie,
but you've got to return
the meat. (laughing)
- I know, I've gotta throw.
- You have to throw meat
to this man.
- I gotta throw meat to him.
- And you.
- And then deny it?
Like I just don't think
he's a conversationalist,
I think he keeps to himself,
and I come on pretty strong.
- Well, you can say that again, yeah.
- It's definitely my dad coming out in me,
it's like, "Hey, that smells
good, throw me a piece."
- Yeah,
it's only gonna get worse.
- It just happens.
But you know what, it leads
to connection usually.
"Hey, this guy's putting
himself out there,
he almost killed himself
trying to catch my meat."
- Yeah.
- We have a connection.
I'm not mad at him.
- Well, I mean,
I feel like you have two options,
you could just go front door
and be like, "We need to talk
about the meat situation.
My family doesn't believe it,
but it's really not about that anymore,
it's just I feel like, I don't
even know your name, man,"
and then see where it goes.
Or equally valid and maybe more fun
is you need to grill more,
you need to be out there.
In fact, you need to
have meat on the ready,
it doesn't even have to
come from your grill,
just have some meat on the
ready, just a meatball maybe.
- Yeah, just one.
- If you see him, you run in,
you pop it in the
microwave for 30 seconds,
one meatball, 20 seconds, it'll warm up.
And you're like, "I got your meat."
- Not his meat.
"I wanna return the favor."
- "I wanna return the favor,
I wanna return the flavor."
- Oh, yes.
- That's what you say, "I
wanna return the flavor."
He will not catch it, 'cause, I mean.
- He is cool that he threw
that meat at me.
- He's an older guy,
I mean, probably can't see the meatball,
it might need to be a bigger meatball.
- Isn't it cool that he threw the meat?
It's like.
- I can't believe he did it.
I can't believe.
- I mean, I'd rather for him
to give me the silent treatment
having thrown meat my way
than to just not.
- Well, that's what's
so confusing.
- Throw meat my way
and me to feel stupid.
- That's what's so confusing,
because the Venn diagram between people.
- Right.
- Who will throw meat
after being asked one time.
- Yeah.
- And will not then
talk about it later.
- Yeah.
- That doesn't feel like the same person.
- Does he feel like the
connection was so deep,
like it's an affair?
Does he feel that?
- He feels shame.
- Does he feel like he needs
to keep it under wraps,
do I need to?
- Well, he did it
in front of 10 people so I don't think so.
- Maybe.
- But those people
weren't impressed.
- Maybe he was ridiculed,
it was like, yeah, they didn't know
what to say or something.
- I would've clapped,
for one, I would've clapped
if somebody caught meat like that.
- I mean, they definitely
think I'm a redneck, right?
- I don't think they know about rednecks.
- It was a redneck move, wasn't it?
- Well, yeah, it was,
but I don't think that's how
they would categorize it.
- What do you think they think of me?
Strange.
- Well, what else have they
seen you do.
- Strange and outgoing.
- They hear you play your music.
- Yeah.
- They probably hate that.
- They have opinions about that, I'm sure.
- All right, well, thanks
for almost believing me.
- Yeah, I still, yeah, to be clear,
I don't believe any of it.
- Let's get back into childhood.
- What I do believe is that
we've got some hats for sale.
- The Mythical Kitchen's
got a nice-looking hat,
I can't remember what they call this,
spaghetti octopus, octo-spaghetti,
squid-ghetti?
- Something like that.
- It's cool though.
- And here's the, and this
is a total coinkydink,
I got the Feel Good
Mythical Morning hat here,
which is sort of the
dad-style hat in purple,
and I'm wearing
the Feel Good hoodie.
- Ooh, nice.
- 'Cause it just feels good.
- Quite an ensemble.
- Just put it on
for that reason, and that reason alone,
mythical.com, make it
happen, rep your boys.
- Let's see.
- Okay.
- If you could pick one thing
from your childhood to bring
back, what would it be?
- Let's get started with Teresa Dawley,
who said, "Two words, school pizza."
I was so excited about this
because I was thinking,
not necessarily school pizza,
but you know me and food,
you don't have to throw meat
at me to get me excited.
- Yeah.
- I'm always thinking about food,
and I was thinking about the
food that I enjoyed as a lad,
and I was thinking, "How could
I recreate some of the things
that I enjoyed at the Buies
Creek Elementary cafeteria?"
And for us, square or
really rectangular pizza.
- You called it square pizza, but.
- You called it square pizza,
but I wonder how good it would be
if I were to eat a piece right now,
would I be like, "This is the
worst pizza I've ever had,"
'cause it was?
- I didn't like it
at the time.
- You didn't eat the pizza at the time?
- No, I didn't like it.
- You didn't even eat it?
- I didn't even eat it.
- Did you ever try it?
- Yeah, I tried it,
it wasn't horrible, but I
remember it being really soft.
- It was so good,
I would eat other people's
who didn't finish it.
- And it was rectangular
because it was a big sheet.
- And it fit into the tray,
it fit into the section of the tray
that was a rectangular shape
and they just cut it to fit that.
- Our pepperonis were cubed,
were they not?
- Cubed.
Well, so.
- They weren't circular.
- In high school, there
was cubed pepperoni
on triangular pizza, which I also got.
In elementary school, it was cheese pizza
with no pepperoni on it,
it was just cheese pizza.
(Link sneezing)
- Excuse me.
- But then in high school.
- Oh, just cheese, no pepperoni?
- In elementary school, just cheese.
In high school, they
added that middle thing,
or like sophomore year.
- The island.
- The island that had burgers.
- Chicken nugget.
- Chicken sandwiches.
- Oh, yes.
- Which is when I put my shoe in there,
or Betsy Patrick's shoe in there,
I can't remember what happened.
- Yeah.
- And triangular pizza
with cubed pepperonis.
- I don't know that the.
- I liked that,
did you eat that?
Did you eat any of the pizza at school?
- No.
- What did you eat
in high school?
- I brought my lunch.
- Every day?
- I'm pretty sure, in high school,
yeah, I'm pretty sure.
- I don't think I brought my lunch
ever in high school.
- Yeah,
I had to have my pudding cup,
I had to have.
- I was like,
"I'm in high school now, I'm
kinda becoming an adult."
- No, you're not.
- "It's time to stop
bringing your lunch."
- I don't think that school
pizza would stand up now.
- But, boy, I'd really like to taste it
just to know what, just how good,
if it could be as good as
it was to me back then now,
man.
- It seems like this should be
like a line in the freezer section,
like School Pizza, just lean into it,
but make it taste good.
It's a good idea, right?
- So it'd be square pizza,
what else would you have?
- Just that, just that,
let's just start there.
- Just call it School Pizza.
- Yeah.
- And it's square.
- Mm-hmm.
- And there's cheese, of course,
and there's a couple of different flavors.
- And yeah, there's a cup
of pudding in there too,
can we do that?
- No.
- Yes we can.
- Nobody wants that.
- Yeah, we can.
Staying with school, Jamie
Mitchell Naragon tweeted,
"Parachute Day in gym class."
- Yeah.
- Yes, elementary school,
Coach Ellzey would
break out the parachute,
and that was something.
How did the parachute become a thing,
I mean, was it that like
parachutists would just,
I guess they would just abandon
their parachutes and then,
or there was just too
many parachutes around
so then they started figuring out ways
to use them in PE class?
- Do you think he had the
parachute at all times
or do you think it was like
carried from school to school?
- No, yeah, well, he
had a nice storage area,
he had a storage room.
But all the members of the
class would grab the parachute
and you'd put a ball in the middle
and you'd flap that thing
to make the ball go up.
Am I correct in that, two things,
first of all, I remember there
being a hole in the middle?
And I also remember.
- There is a hole
in the middle.
- Playing a game
where you would throw it up,
you would fluff it up,
and when it was in the air,
you would run underneath.
- You wouldn't run underneath,
you'd pick it up.
- Like you'd designate
a person to run underneath.
- And you'd pull it
behind you and sit down.
- And you'd all be underneath it.
- And everybody would be underneath it
and you'd be like, "We're in a room,
we're in a room."
- But wasn't there a game
where it's like they would
choose someone to run across
and get to the other side?
- Maybe,
maybe, yeah.
- Boy, that was thrilling.
- I watched a YouTube video
that was a giant parachute,
it was like hundreds of people
doing one of these things,
it was not a real parachute,
it was just one that was designed for.
- Like popping up a ball,
what were they doing with it?
- No, no, they were just
doing it really high
and getting underneath it.
- It makes you feel small in a good way.
- How often do you think
Parachute Day happened?
I think it was twice a year
at most.
- Twice a year, yeah,
it was special when it came out.
- But why, why was it so,
that's why, I don't
think it was in storage,
I don't know, I think you
might have bad information.
I think it would be like,
"Well, it's at Erwin today."
"It's in Lillington today."
"It's in Dunn today,
we got one parachute for the county."
- But I think we would know,
we would associate the parachute
with a parachute person,
but I don't recall any
parachute person showing up
when the parachute was there.
- Well, the parachute guy
drops off the parachute
before you get to school.
- I think it's more about how
if you play with that
parachute four days in a row,
you discover that like, "Oh."
- "We're not really doing anything."
- "This actually sucks."
- Yeah.
- But when it's once
or twice a school year, it's special,
but Coach Ellzey knew
when to take it away,
and he knew when to bring it back.
- Well, but Jamie says, "Followed
closely by Scooter Day,"
and now the scooters
that are pictured here
are these, basically, a plastic platform
with handles and four
wheels, I remember these.
- The wheels are like casters.
- Casters, yeah.
- That you would
put underneath,
like a speaker cabinet.
- This is a
very dangerous toy.
- I don't remember this.
- We didn't have these,
I know I've seen these before,
but I don't think I've ever been on one
and we definitely didn't have them
at Buies Creek.
- Wouldn't that mess up
the gym floor?
I guess you would do that
outside on the cement.
- You can do this
on the concrete.
- And you would kinda,
it was kinda like a,
is it, not rollerblade, sit and skate,
it was like a sit and skate,
but a much more rudimentary design.
- I don't know what you're talking about.
- I don't remember this, Jamie,
we didn't have those at Buies
Creek Elementary School.
- I've got one,
flattop haircuts.
- Flattop haircuts, well,
just go into the military.
- Well, they were really, now, I had one.
- Yep, you had one for a while.
- And Rudolph Blanchard would cut it in,
and then basically, it's like a buzz
that's about that short, like
almost bald in the middle,
and of course, they make up for it
by being a little bit higher on the sides.
And then he would give you this thing
that you put one of your fingers through.
- Like a plastic comb
that would fit in the palm of your hand
and go over one finger.
- And he would be like,
"And you gotta keep it up,
you gotta keep it up."
I don't remember him giving
me any product for it, but.
- I never had that haircut,
but I remember the comb.
- You never had a buzz until college.
- Well, high school,
when we started cutting each
other's hair in high school.
- You did a buzz in high school?
- Yeah.
- It's funny, this is
something that I've noticed
when I kinda go back to the South,
there is a sort of a thing,
and it was very common
when we were coming up,
but it's just like you
shave all the boys' heads,
like, (laughing) if there's a family
with a bunch of boys in it,
everybody's got a shaved head.
And like we did that for, we
had buzzes for years on end.
Do you remember the buzz days,
like me and Cahal both had buzzes,
buzzes or flattops, like flattop
was as extravagant.
- You're talking about
in elementary school,
yeah, yeah.
- Yeah,
and the funny thing is
my wife would never have
let that happen to my boys.
And I know it's like a generational thing,
but like she was always interested
in them just having hair.
- Well.
- They never asked for a buzz.
- It was the style though, it was, I mean.
- But if you go back to the South,
there's still kids that just have buzzes,
it's just like, "Yeah, he's got a buzz."
- Mm-hmm, yeah, at this point in time,
in that environment, I think
it's just to simplify things.
- Now, I.
- Why do you miss it?
- Well, I bring it up
because I wanna present this
as a question to you.
- Yeah.
- Okay, so at some point, I'm
going to cut my hair, right,
now, listen, it could
be five years from now,
and I'm not saying I'm
gonna just let it grow,
I've already trimmed it once,
I'll probably trim it again,
it's getting to be kinda out of control,
I'm gonna try to like get
it a little bit closer,
but for the foreseeable future,
I plan on having some sort
of long haircut, right,
but I'm not gonna have it forever,
you gotta make a bold hair choice.
And the question is, whether
it's a year from now,
two years from now, five years from now,
I have to go back to something,
I have to go to something,
I have to transition from
this to something else.
And I've talked to Jessie about this,
I was like, "I think when I," (laughing)
and she gets so mad,
I was like, "I think when
I get rid of this hair,
I'm going to buzz it"
. I was like, "I don't
think that I'm going to try
to cut it into a haircut,
I think I'm gonna buzz it,"
and maybe I'll be like,
"Huh, the buzz works."
- Well, you know
you're not gonna get rid of your beard,
you feel like you're gonna die
with a beard with a beard.
- Oh, no, no,
I'm not getting rid of my beard.
- You're gonna die with a beard
and that's a big factor in this.
- The only reason I
would get rid of my beard
is if I was trying to like,
if I become so committed
to like a spiritual
discipline of detachment.
- The proof would be in that pudding,
with a pizza.
- 'Cause it would be
difficult for me to deal
with my unshaven face
because I'm ashamed of it.
- Yeah, that's the real test.
- So maybe I'll get to
some spiritual level
where that's what I do,
but, no, I'm talking about
still having a beard.
And I've never had that
combo, buzz with big beard,
it might be a good look.
- Well.
- Flattop with big beard.
- I think there's gonna
come a day.
- Flattop.
- Again, if the beard gets bigger, then.
- The beard can't get
any bigger than it did.
- Yeah, but if it got.
- 'Cause it starts,
it grows and I can't.
- If it got that big,
I think you could, I mean,
your hair's kinda pulled back,
you're kinda simulating something
which has the shape of a buzz,
it actually would not feel that
much different, it wouldn't.
- So what do you think about it?
- I like it, I like the idea.
- Oh, you like it.
- Well, I think
you should go with flattop,
like Owen Wilson.
- Flattop,
that's what I'm feeling.
- In Bottle Rocket flattop.
- Big beard and like a Guile flattop.
- I mean, Owen Wilson's
flattop in that movie,
Wes Anderson's first movie, Bottle Rocket,
it's pronounced, it's
like a 2 1/2 inch tall,
it's got some Guile qualities to it.
- My hair might not support.
- No, I don't think it would.
- My hair's too curly and it wouldn't be,
you would need that to be
real tight and real uniform,
but a buzz, anybody can support a buzz.
- Yeah.
- My wife would hate it,
she would hate it.
- Mm, I actually don't,
again, when the hair's pulled back,
it's not that much different.
You know what I'm gonna do,
there is gonna be a day
when I'ma grow a beard,
I'ma grow big beard and it's.
- And I'm gonna get glasses
and then we're gonna.
- I know you're gonna,
you're not gonna get rid of your beard,
but I wanna have a total
beard at some point.
But because it's so white, it
makes me look so much older
that I'm not ready to do it.
- You'd look like Santa Claus.
- But at a certain point.
- Well, the longer you wait,
the more white it'll be.
- Well, yeah, but it'll
be like Letterman's beard,
like it's white and huge,
and then he has no hair on his head,
of course, he's bald.
- He's bald.
- But I can do a buzz.
- Yeah, I actually had big,
I had high hopes.
- You had big hopes?
- For having like a really big beard,
but the terminal length
of the middle of my beard,
I reached it and it just grows on the side
and it becomes a giant unwieldy square.
And I'm just like, "Okay, that's it,
I reached max beard length.
- Yeah, I wanna see
what would happen to mine, I don't know.
But I don't miss the flattop,
I don't miss any of the haircuts
I ever had, none of 'em.
- At no point?
- At no point.
- But you only had two haircuts
before this one, lifetime.
- (laughing) Yeah, well.
- You had the same haircut
all through elementary school,
basically, and then you had.
- Well, I mean,
it's all chronicled in
the Book of Mythicality.
(Rhett laughing)
If you wanna go back
to that, but.
Sweet Peach-Candy,
@passionatecandy responded to us,
"I wish I could bring back
some of the 80s' cartoons,
they were some of the best,
from Jem, to She-Ra, to ThunderCats,
Saturday mornings were awesome.
Thankfully I can re-watch all my favorites
to remind myself and
relive the nostalgia."
So that's Saturday-morning cartoons,
and then somebody, she
mentioned ThunderCats,
Marcus Nordberg also
"I wish they would make a
new movie with ThunderCats.
Great content and always
with a nice wholesome lesson
at the end to sum it all up."
Now, in an ad read that we
did, I mentioned ThunderCats
and how I thought it should come back,
I don't know if I planted this thought
amongst the Mythical Beasts.
But I watched the first
episode of ThunderCats,
like I just put it on.
- Recently?
- Recently, yeah,
like a couple of weeks ago.
- Was it awful?
- Well, it starts off really interesting,
like the pilot episode, like
the origin story of Lion-O.
- The lion?
- He's a teen, he's a preteen,
he's like prepubescent boy.
- A boy.
- And he's in this futuristic environment
where all these like
anthropomorphized cats
are walking around and
defending their fortress
against these evil people.
But all of the cats that you grow to love,
that are like the key
characters of ThunderCats,
they start off in the
pilot episode naked, naked.
Now, I say naked because when you picture
or Google any of the
ThunderCat characters,
they have suits on.
- They have suits on.
- But when I watched the pilot episode,
I'm like, "Oh, my gosh, they are,
"well, they're cats, but they
don't have any clothes on,"
and they're walking around
like humans and there's.
- What, is there a bulge, or what is it?
- Well, there's the leopard woman,
who like has these sexy curves,
and I mean, she looks like,
you know, like Jennifer
Lawrence in the X-Men movies
when like she's just blue
and she's basically naked
except without nipples?
- I have no idea what
you're talking about,
I've never thought about
that, I've never dwelt on it.
- A nipple-less Jennifer Lawrence is blue,
yeah, of course.
- I never picture it
in the quiet moments.
- Me neither.
- Right.
- So I don't know
what you're talking about.
- I'm basically making
this up.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- This is just like
a pop culture reference.
- This is like the whole
meat in your mouth thing.
- That I've heard
from someone.
(Rhett laughing)
- (laughing) If I would've
caught it in my mouth,
that would've been amazing.
- Such dirty old men.
We're such dirty old men.
- Well, listen,
I'm watching this with my family,
I'm like making them watch ThunderCats,
and the first thing, I'm
like, "They're naked.
That leopard woman,
she's naked and she doesn't have nipples,"
that's the best way I can describe it,
that's the most accurate way
I could describe it.
- Which is exactly like, yeah.
- And they knew it too,
because like, I mean, she
was strutting her stuff,
and at one point, she winks at the camera.
- She knows what's up.
- She winks at the camera.
- [Rhett] Mm-hmm.
- And then through a series
of events, they get clothes,
like this is part of their origin story.
- Ah.
- But they were already
fully their characters, they
just didn't have clothes,
but then they were given clothes.
But for a while there, they are all naked.
- Was it established who
gave them the clothes,
or they just showed up with clothes?
- I can't even remember that,
once they got clothed, I stopped watching.
- Yeah, it was like, "This
is an interesting angle."
- So it's like, yeah,
I mean, it doesn't hold up
once they get clothes.
- Yeah.
- But before that,
it is pretty exciting.
- I could imagine that.
- I don't think it should come back,
I think that first half
of the pilot episode
is all you need.
- But here's the thing
is that when you talk about television,
just like Passionate Candy
has pointed out here,
you can get it to come back
just by watching it again.
Like that's the wonderful
thing about media.
- But the Saturday-morning
cartoon experience
is something that kids
these days don't have.
Like I remember I would
have to get up early enough
to make sure I didn't miss Smurfs.
- Well, that's what John
Bailey is talking about here,
@baileyjohn75.
- Oh, yeah.
- "Appointment television.
Back in the day, we had a weekly schedule
of our favorite shows, Friday was TGIF,
Tuesday was The Office, et cetera,
now we just binge a season in a week."
And I mean, this guy, John is
significantly younger than us
'cause he's talking about
appointment television
and he says, "The Office,"
like we were adults when
The Office came out.
- Mm-hmm.
- But when The Office did first come out,
it was, oh, you had to
watch it Tuesday on NBC and.
- Oh, yeah, and I remember
when Lost first came out
and I was working as an
engineer at the time,
and like you would watch it
because that's what everyone
would be talking about
at lunch the next day,
it was like that classic
water cooler conversation,
like that literally
happened to me every week.
We had a water cooler,
you would stand at it
and you would have a
conversation about Lost.
"What, there's a polar
bear on the island."
- "Yeah, they can't explain that."
- "I don't know what's going on there."
- Don't worry, they won't. (laughing)
- And I mean, it was a
big motivating factor
of going to work, 'cause I
had something I'd watched
that now I could talk about it.
- Well, I mean, this made me think about,
I mean, we're never going
back to this place, right?
I mean, now that, this
is just not gonna happen
unless the bottom drops out
technologically speaking.
- Or are we?
I mean, like the way
that Disney Plus is releasing
all of their series.
- Yeah, but, I mean, that's.
- I mean, like we made
an appointment to watch
The Mandalorian and
WandaVision, so every week
we look forward to those.
- Well, I do think that
that's part of the philosophy behind
why HBO hasn't strayed
from the weekly release
and Disney Plus is doing it
is that the conversation
around WandaVision lasted.
- Yeah, the duration of Season One really.
- So there is definitely strategy,
but I think that the
product that you're selling
has to be good enough
to be able to compete
without being binged.
- Game of Thrones, yep.
- But it made me think about,
not just appointment television,
but going all the way
back to our childhoods,
where it wasn't just, "This is
when the shows are coming on
and you watch 'em or you don't,"
but just the number of channels.
And like I'm talking 80s,
I'm talking basically three
channels and PBS, maybe.
- Yeah.
- Like I remember,
I feel like I remember, maybe I don't,
I feel like I remember
when Fox became a channel,
or when we first got it,
'cause all I remember was
NBC, CBS and ABC and PBS.
And I was thinking about this
in the context of our society,
and one of the things that
people have talked about
is one of the things that's contributing
to the high level of polarization
is everybody gets their news
from their own source, right?
- Yeah.
- And back in the day,
it was like, well, if
Walter Cronkite said it,
you believed it, and
that was the only source.
There are definitely times when I'm like.
- Well, we didn't watch Walter,
but we watched Dan Rather.
- Dan Rather, Sam Donaldson.
- Yep, Tom Brokaw.
- Sam Donaldson he makes
appearances on news now.
- Really, I've seen Dan Rather
make appearances.
- Well, Dan Rather is like.
- He's still doing stuff.
- Still totally with it
and making funny tweets.
- Yeah.
- And he's in
the conversation, he'll be a guest,
but Sam Donaldson, who
even when he retired,
his eyebrows were already
doing incredible things.
- He's like a Muppet.
In the best way possible, yeah.
- They're doing even more
unspeakable things now.
- Oh, really?
- And yeah,
I don't know, I can't remember who,
he'll come on and talk to
somebody, one of these anchors.
But anyway, it just makes me think about,
boy, the simpler times of,
A, not caring at all about the news,
and then if you did care about the news,
you all cared about the
same news, I miss that.
- Oh, yeah, and when it
came to television shows,
you watched stuff that you didn't like
because you had to watch something.
- You know what, and I think
that changed everything for us.
Again, I don't wanna be the old fart
who says, "Well, this
generation, and back in my day,"
but one of the things I do think
is that our options for what
we could watch were so few
that it kinda transferred over
into everything that we could experience.
Like even when we think about
what we're gonna eat as a
family, my dad would just say,
"We're going to the Mexican
restaurant in Fuquay Varina,"
it wasn't like,
"Where do you guys wanna eat?"
- Yeah.
- I mean, yes, you got to make a decision
on what you were gonna
eat once you got there,
they didn't order for you,
but where you were gonna eat
and when you were gonna eat
was not a family conference.
- Uh-huh.
- But now,
everything's a family conference.
And you got kids who have
been empowered to the point
that they can make all these choices,
and they're like, "Well, I don't like that
and I don't like that
and I don't want that, well,
we don't wanna watch that."
Just sitting down to try
to watch a movie together,
like what is your process
for making a decision
or suggesting a family movie?
- I've given up, man.
- Because that's gotten
out of hand in my family sometimes.
- But that's why we only watch Survivor.
(Rhett laughing)
Like, I mean, because nobody's tired of it
and there's just more and more seasons
and there's no conversation, we just keep,
the only conversation is,
"Are we gonna watch another one or not?"
- Well, I've had some success
with choosing family movies,
but there's a lot of pressure,
and I feel like they believe me that I,
but there was one, what
was it, what did I?
Oh, (laughing) we had
watched Tombstone, right?
- Yeah, okay.
- And so everybody
was on board for Tombstone,
great movie, holds up, kids loved it.
- Next night, Wyatt Earp.
- No, we didn't go Wyatt
Earp, I went too hard,
I went all the way to Unforgiven.
- That's, mm-hmm.
- Clint Eastwood, Unforgiven,
like one of his later, I mean,
well, he's been around forever,
but yeah.
- That's a great movie,
but it's a little more intense, isn't it?
No, what's wrong with it?
- Well, I'm trying to remember
what ended up happening,
I think we ended up
getting through it, but.
- Morgan Freeman and Clint Eastwood.
- It's an incredible movie.
- Is it slow, is it, I can't remember,
what could be bad about it?
- It's just, well, I mean,
Tombstone is like real funny
and a little bit more lighthearted,
Unforgiven is just a little bit,
I mean, it starts out with like
the woman's face getting
cut up and stuff, it's like.
- Oh, oh, yeah.
I don't remember the details.
- (sighing) It starts out
a little rough, so I lost their trust.
But what I'm saying, my point is,
is that when my dad came home with a VCR,
first of all, he came home
with the VCR.
(Link laughing)
- He rented the VCR.
- Like he didn't buy the VCR,
he rented the VCR and the VHS tapes
and walked in the door, and I was like,
"I don't care what he has, he has a VCR."
- It's a movie in our house.
- "We have a movie in our house,
this is the peak of society,"
is what I was thinking.
And it didn't matter what movie we played.
And he would rent two movies,
rent it for two days, right?
- Mm-hmm.
- Watch one one night,
watch one the next night,
two best nights of my life.
Boy, my kids are much harder to please.
- When you're talking about
like linear programming
and if you miss it, you miss it,
like even if you really
had to go to the bathroom
during Seinfeld, it's like,
you would miss something,
(laughing) and you couldn't get it back.
You'd have to ask somebody about,
you'd have to infer that part.
If somebody called you on the phone
and you didn't screen it,
you'd miss that part of it.
- Some people did record on a VHS.
I mean, you told me
that your father-in-law.
- Oh, yeah, he was still.
- Was still using a VCR
to record soap operas
as recently as like two years ago.
- Yeah, I think he still does even now.
- (laughing) Really?
- Yeah, I think he does.
I guess he doesn't wanna be
in the house during the day.
But we were talking about
doing some sort of like,
we have so much content,
we've tossed around the idea,
it's come up a number
of times of doing like.
- A channel.
- A Mythical channel
that's just constantly playing
and you can go in there
and watch whatever's
playing at that moment
with whoever else is
watching at that time.
Like you just have a program.
- Well, if you took
every Good Mythical Morning,
every Good Mythical MORE.
- 24 hours.
- Every Ear Biscuit, every sketch,
every short-form thing,
everything we've done on
Instagram, TikTok, whatever,
and you just put it back to
back, to back, to back, to back,
I mean, how much content would that be
before it repeated itself?
At least a month.
- The problem is,
from a business standpoint,
I think it would be fun,
but first of all, it would be.
- A difficult technical exercise.
- Well, to answer your question,
"How long would it be,"
I think Jacob did something
where it was like,
if it was just Good Mythical Morning,
I mean, we could do the math right quite,
even we just say 10
minutes an episode times,
let's just go ahead
and say 2,000 episodes.
- That's 20,000 minutes.
- That's 20,000 minutes
divided by 60 is, six will go into 2,000.
- It's 3,000, 3,000 hours,
that doesn't make sense.
- I think that's right.
- We just did the math.
- It's a little
over 3,000 hours.
No.
- That sounds crazy.
- I can't do math in my head right now.
- Well, use your calculator.
- Okay.
- But from a business standpoint,
we couldn't justify it,
it's a lot of trouble to make that happen.
I think it would be cool.
- Oh.
- I think you might be thinking.
- It's 300, 333 hours,
so we were off by a factor of 10.
But you divide that by 24,
so it's two weeks, 14 day.
- Only two weeks.
- But that's just GMM,
and also you're
underestimating the average
length of an episode.
- Yeah.
- And then you add in Good Mythical MOREs
and you basically double
that, that's a month.
And then you throw in everything else,
you're gonna get at least a
week of stuff that we've done,
maybe, I don't know, maybe half a week.
- Yeah, and we can.
- Yeah, we got at least
a month of content.
- And you rerun stuff.
- The reason that I still think
that it might be not that bad of an idea
is because you can,
the whole idea of linear
viewing of anything
is the connection between other people
who are experiencing it
at the same time, right?
- Yeah.
- So it's just like, hey,
we go to the website
where they're streaming The Mythical Show,
Mythical Show would be on there too,
The Mythical TV Channel,
and then you go on the chatroom
and you talk about it in the moment.
- Right.
- Like, "Oh, this is
that old thing they did a long time ago,
I forgot all about it."
I still think there's something to it.
- Now that we're talking about it,
I think people are gonna ask for it.
- Yeah.
- I mean,
there's kids channels on YouTube
that get millions of views on their videos
and then they just make this livestream
that's this concept.
- And they do it because parents
wanna be able to put their kids
in front of something that is passive
for a longer period of time.
- Yeah.
- I don't know, maybe we should
think about it some more.
- Okay, Kena, Kena.
- [Both] Kleepbleep.
- "Having sleepovers with my best friend
and laughing all the time."
- Dang, man, I mean, I miss that.
Like, I mean, would it be weird
if I was like, "Hey,
can I come over tonight,
"we can just sleep on the
couches in your living room?"
- Yeah, it would be,
yeah.
- Yeah, it would be weird
if you did that at my house too.
- But I'm trying to think.
- So it's not me that's weird,
it's the act, I just wanna clarify that.
- Well, I'm try to figure out,
why do friends stop sleepovers?
'Cause like, as a kid, part of
the whole idea of a sleepover
is we're gonna stay up late,
you don't want your parent
to have to come pick
you up later, whatever,
there's a sense of adventure
waking up in the morning.
I mean, why don't friends, adult friends,
I mean, I know that adult friends,
like inside friends, like
John Mayer sings about,
are doing sleepovers.
(Link laughing)
I'm not talking about sexual partners,
I'm talking about platonic
friendships as adults,
planned sleepovers.
- Well, when you have.
- I'm not talking about like,
"Hey, man, can I crash here?"
I'm talking about, "Hey,
Friday night, sleepover,"
how come that doesn't happen?
- Maybe it does happen
with single friends,
but like if you have a partner,
if you have children in the house,
it's associated with kids
and then it starts to feel weird.
- You're telling me that you think
that single people without children
are planning sleepovers as
adult friends right now?
- I haven't heard of it,
but I didn't wanna.
- I don't think
that's a thing.
- Yeah, that should be a thing.
- And you set up a little fort?
- Well.
- And see that's where
it gets to be like a kid though.
Where are you gonna
sleep, that's what it is,
the adult body needs a bed.
- A bedroom.
- Needs their own bed that
they're familiar with.
When you're a kid, I could
sleep on a gym floor,
I could sleep anywhere,
I could sleep in a chair,
I could sleep on a fence.
- I mean, whenever I would
sleep over at your house.
- I gave you a nice mattress.
- You had a mattress underneath your bed
and you would pull that out
and I would sleep on that.
- Yeah.
- Or sometimes,
we would both sleep in the guest room
'cause there was a couch
and a mattress in there,
or maybe you'd move the mattress.
- I would also just put a sleeping bag
on the carpet and sleep,
it was not a problem.
- But so what would we do now,
because, yeah, it is difficult
when you're like, "Well, you know what,
I'm kinda sleepy, I'm gonna go
to my bed with my wife."
- "To my bed."
- And, oh, okay, well,
I'm gonna lay on the floor
by you and Jesse,
(laughing) or vice versa?
It's like, "Well, I'm just
gonna sleep on your couch."
- You'd get a sleeping
bag and sleep next to us.
Yeah, that's what you'd do.
- No, I think we would both
need to sleep in the living room
together.
- In a different room.
(Rhett laughing)
- You can't sleep in your own bed.
- Yeah, I don't think
this is gonna happen,
and I think we discovered why.
- I mean, I've gotta.
- It's the comfort of your own bed,
adults value that too much, why am
I gonna sleep on the floor?
- Yeah,
even if it's 3:00 a.m.,
I'm gonna go back home.
- It's not worth it,
I'm driving home.
- I'm gonna go back home
and I'm gonna get in my bed,
I don't wanna wake up at your house.
- Yeah.
- That's strange.
- That's exactly what it is.
And then you wake up in the morning
and then you're like,
"Oh, are we eating breakfast together,
like what happens now?"
Yeah, you don't want.
- Well, I was thinking we
should talk ourselves into it.
I mean, if you're.
- Well, we could do
a vlog about it, for sure.
- Again, when your kids come downstairs
and like you and your best friend
are like asleep on the couch. (laughing)
But if your single, single
friends should be sleeping over.
This is a movement, I mean,
we can do it for them.
Are we missing something,
I think this would work.
- Air mattresses,
air mattresses.
- Yeah, you can get
a air mattress.
So, I mean, a lot of single people,
they'll have like another
bed, might have a guest bed.
- It may.
- But that's not a sleepover,
if you're not sleeping
in the same room.
- You gotta be sleeping
- You gotta sleep
in the same room.
- Because the second part
of this is, "And laughing all the time,"
and I think, Kena, you may not necessarily
be putting these two things together,
but I'm taking that, that's how
I'm interpreting this, because that's
the fun of a sleepover is.
- Oh, yeah, "Sleepovers
and laughing all the time."
- Sleepover, making each other laugh,
not being able to shut up,
having my dad come up the
stairs and get mad at us
because we were so loud
'cause we wouldn't stop laughing
about something, like yeah.
- Yeah.
- But that level of laugh attack,
that's also a difficult
thing to attain as an adult.
- Well that's where alcohol comes in.
- Ah, okay, drunk sleepovers.
- (laughing) Yeah, I mean, we're adults.
- Okay, all right.
- I mean, going on a trip somewhere,
like getting an Airbnb with
your friend or friends,
that's a sleepover that's
still acceptable, but.
- But you sleep in different rooms,
everybody gets their own room.
- But you sleep in
different rooms, hmm.
- But that is a form of a sleepover.
- I insist on this coming back.
It's just you gotta remove the stigma.
Keep the platonic nature intact,
but get rid of the stigma, sleepovers.
"Hey, kids, Rhett's sleeping
over tonight, we're gonna be."
You got a big couch in there,
hey, it's an open invitation.
- Oh, okay.
- You're thinking about it.
- Well, yeah,
we'll consider it, tell us
what you think about it.
But I really like this one,
this one has a sort of a feel to it,
from Len, ljc062179.
(Rhett laughing)
- Okay.
"Late summer nights sitting
under the streetlight
with your neighborhood best friends,
discussing the universe, life,
and how you would be friends forever,
not knowing that life would
make most of you drift apart
and catch you up in the
rat race of adulthood,
to be young again."
- Hmm, well, I mean,
I don't mean to rub it
in, Len, but that's kinda
what we're still doing.
(Rhett laughing)
So I'm sorry you don't have that.
But, I mean, I definitely remember,
when we would have sleepovers,
we would go out and we would
lay down in the pitch dark,
we would lay down in the
middle of the street,
on like the paved road
in front of my house.
So few cars would come
down the road at night
that we would lay down
in the middle of the road
just because it was a funny thing to do.
I remember that our neighbor came outside
when he saw us like walking
around outside in the dark,
and he was like, "Link, you okay,
have you been drinking?"
- Oh, I don't remember this.
- Yeah, and I was like, "No, no, no, no,
we're just hanging out outside."
- Yeah, that's what we'd do.
- We hadn't been drinking,
but he was patrolling
us, as Christy would say.
- And do not try this at home.
- Yeah, don't lay out in the street.
- But we lived on.
- If a car came,
we would get up.
- You lived on a super, super,
I mean, I lived on a dead-end,
but you lived on a country road that,
the cars were flying,
but you could hear 'em coming
from a mile away, literally.
And yeah, we'd just get out there,
and there were no
streetlights, first of all.
- No.
- It was pitch black,
or it was just the moonlight,
and you'd lay right on
the double yellow line.
And you just felt like.
- The road was still warm
at night.
- Yeah, but there was
just something about that lying
in the middle of the road,
which you knew was like, "At
any minute a car could come,
and I'm just gonna be
looking up into the sky."
Yeah, there's something to that.
Living in a place where you can lie
in the middle of the road
there's just, yeah.
- Yeah, I miss that.
- I guess I could lie
in like the neighborhood street
in front of my house, but.
- Yeah, I live on a dead-end road now.
- Somebody would call somebody.
- I mean if I walked
outside and saw my kid,
one of my kids and his friend
laying in the middle of the
cul-de-sac, I'd be like,
"I get it, I get it."
- Yeah, yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- "I'll be back inside,
sleeping over with my adult friend."
- "You guys been drinking?"
(Link laughing)
- Yeah, man, Saturday-morning cartoons,
what do you remember watching?
I remember Smurfs, I remember,
it was a show called Shirt Tales,
they had little stuffed animals
that you could get at Hardee's.
If it was worth watching,
it was worth having its own little thing
at like the Hardee's
version of a Happy Meal.
California Raisins had a
cartoon, but I didn't watch that,
I did watch the Gummi Bears cartoon.
- Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah I watched that.
I watched the Care Bears cartoon.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah,
that was a big one.
- Was it on one channel
or did multiple channels have
Saturday-morning cartoons?
- For a while, all three
had Saturday-morning cartoons.
- So did you choose a channel
or did you switch?
- I don't remember, there
was a Mr. T cartoon,
I liked that a lot.
And then at a certain point,
they would switch over
to being live action,
so, I mean, you'd get like
the Saved by the Bells of the world
and that type of stuff.
- When did you stop
getting up early to watch
Saturday-morning cartoons?
- I don't remember, I don't know,
I don't remember losing
interest, but I did.
- I definitely was not
getting up at middle school.
- Hmm, yeah, I don't think so.
- I was sleeping until like 1:00 o'clock
by the time I was like in seventh grade,
Saturday.
- Yeah, 'cause at that point,
you'd stay up late, yeah.
That was nice to go down memory lane, man,
get yourself some animated Gummi Bears,
get that taste in your mouth.
- Thanks for your
responses to that prompt,
keep the conversation going
on the internet, #EarBiscuits.
- I got a rec though.
- Oh, yeah, Link's got a rec.
- It's my rec time.
I'm gonna go back to music
for this recommendation.
I watched, well, I guess I'll
recommend the documentary too,
I watched The Bee Gees documentary,
it's on HBO, 96% on Rotten Tomatoes,
How Can You Mend a Broken
Heart is the name of it.
It doesn't talk about their personal lives
just enough for it to be
a backdrop to the music,
so it is a music-centric documentary,
it doesn't talk about, I don't know,
the drug use, or you know, it goes into,
I mean, there was three brothers
and then two of 'em died,
and well, there were four brothers,
but the youngest brother
was not a member of the band
until much later, he was
kinda like grandfathered in,
no pun unintended, but they're
all dead except for Barry,
who's arguably the most
recognizable Bee Gee.
- The beard and long-haired
one.
- Yeah,
but the documentary's great
if you're into music
documentaries, like I am,
and there's so many fascinating
points in their career,
like the fact that they
completely reinvented themselves
into what you know as the Bee Gees,
first and foremost, like
defining sound of the Disco era
and like that falsetto voice
is something that they discovered
as like a second wind in their career.
And I love those types of stories
in the specifics of how
they discovered that sound
with that song, Jive Talkin'.
And then when they released
it to the radio stations,
they didn't put their name on it,
'cause they didn't want people
to associate it with the Bee Gees
because the Bee Gees were
associated with like,
they came out of the Beatles era
and they were associated
with kind of like this folksy movement,
and they had a lot of hits from that era,
but then they kinda had a stigma,
that then when they
were basically inventing
and defining what disco would sound like
before it got crapped on,
yeah, they didn't wanna use their name.
And it became a hit and they were like,
"Whoa, that's the same Bee Gees?
Like they're singing in another register,
this is totally different."
- What did they say that they were?
They were just like band unnamed?
- They didn't put the name on the record,
I don't think they used a pseudonym,
as far as I can remember,
from the documentary,
they just didn't say,
it was just like, Jive Talkin', play it,"
and then they were playing it
before they knew it was the Bee Gees
and then deciding that they loved it.
But the one song that I'm obsessed with,
because there's a stigma
around the Bee Gees
and like the Disco era,
and like they get into that,
they explain all of that too,
and how they were brought down,
but they didn't deserve it.
And people like Justin
Timberlake are in the documentary
standing up for the Bee
Gees, rightfully so.
And I had not intentionally avoided them,
but I had missed all
these amazing harmonies,
and their melody structures
are just like so enticing.
But the one song that I'm
obsessed with is Too Much Heaven.
- Hmm.
- Too Much Heaven,
listen to that song
and if you like it, then you
can watch the documentary,
but it's just so sweet, man.
(upbeat music)
It is sweet.
- Well, if you want some sweet tunes,
tune into Too Much
Heaven from the Bee Gees.
And we'll catch you next week
on another episode of Ear Biscuits.
- Yeah.
(upbeat music)
To watch more Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist on the right.
- [Rhett] To watch the previous
episode of Ear Biscuit,
click on the playlist to the left.
- [Link] And don't forget to click on
the circular icon to subscribe.
- [Rhett] If you'd prefer
to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your Mythical best.